- BROTHERS.
BROTHERS, LET US BEGIN.
I HAVE CONVENED THIS MEETING
TO FIND OUT WHAT YOU ARE DOING.
WHY HAVE WE NOT TAKEN A PLANE
IN 13 YEARS?
- KHALIV.
YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW.
IT IS ALL BECAUSE THE CUNNING
AND MIGHTY TSA
IS ALWAYS ONE STEP AHEAD OF US.
- I DO NOT BELIEVE IT!
- IT'S TRUE.
LAST MONTH,
I ATTEMPTED TO TAKE DOWN A PLANE
WITH A PAIR OF SCISSORS
FIVE INCHES LONG.
- THAT SOUNDS
LIKE A PERFECT PLAN.
WHY DID IT NOT WORK?
- BECAUSE THE SHREWD TSA,
THEY MADE RESTRICTIONS
SO YOU CAN ONLY
TAKE A FOUR-INCH SCISSORS.
FOUR INCHES.
- WHAT?
- YEAH.
- HOW COULD THEY KNOW
THAT A FIVE-INCH BLADE
IS A DANGEROUS WEAPON
AND A FOUR-INCH BLADE
IS NO MORE
THAN A CHILD'S PLAY THING?
- THAT IS THE GENIUS OF TSA.
THEY FOIL US AT EVERY TURN.
- DEVILS!
- YOU KNOW, IT'S THE SAME WAY
WITH THE LIQUID.
- OH, YEAH.
- WE ALL KNOW
HOW MUCH DEVASTATION
WE CAN WREAK WITH 3.5 OUNCES
OF LIQUID.
- THE--THE DAMAGE
IS INCALCULABLE.
- THE CRAFTY TSA,
THEY HAVE LIMITED PASSENGERS
TO ONLY 3.4 OUNCES.
- DAMN IT!
- YEAH.
- DO NONE OF YOU
HAVE THE SOLUTION HOW--
FOR US TO THWART THIS TSA?
- KHALIV, KHALIV.
IT'S LIKE YOU'VE BEEN
LIVING IN A--WELL, HERE.
LOOK...THE TSA,
THEY STRIKE FEAR INTO MY HEART
WITH THEIR POLYESTER SHIRTS
AND THEIR DISPOSABLE RUBBER
GLOVES.
AND THE--AND THE--
THE SNEAKER SHOES!
- THEY ARE SO CLEVER.
- CLEVER.
- YES.
THEY--THEY ACT AS IF THEY ARE
LISTLESS, OVERWEIGHT EMPLOYEES
WHO DON'T GIVE A FUCK.
WHEN IN REALITY,
THEY ARE AN ELITE FORCE
OF ANTI-TERRORIST COMMANDOS!
- OH, CURSE THE BRILLIANT TSA.
- IF I MAY.
I BELIEVE I HAVE A WAY
TO TRIUMPH OVER THE WILY TSA.
- FINALLY.
- OKAY.
- LET'S GIVE HIM A SHOT.
- I HAVE A PLAN
TO PUT A BOMB IN A LAPTOP,
AND IT WILL DETONATE
ONCE YOU PULL IT FROM ITS CASE.
- YES!
YES, IT IS PERFECT!
PLANES WILL RAIN DOWN
FROM THE SKY ONTO THE INFIDELS!
[all chanting and singing]
WHAT?
PARVEZ, WHAT, WHAT, WHAT?
- S--S--SNEAK IN HERE
FOR A SECOND, 'CAUSE I DON'T--
I DON'T WANT TO BE THE BEARER
OF BAD NEWS HERE--
- THEN DON'T BE!
- YET YOU ARE.
- IT'S AS IF THE PROPHETIC
AND ALL-KNOWING TSA
HAS PREDICTED YOUR PLAN.
THEY MAKE YOU TAKE THE LAPTOP
OUT OF THE CARRYING CASE
AND PUT IT IN A SEPARATE BIN
BEFORE YOU GET ON THE PLANE.
- COME ON,
YOU'VE GOT TO BE KIDDING ME.
ARE YOU KIDDING ME, PARVEZ?
'CAUSE IT'S NOT A FUNNY JOKE
IF IT'S A JOKE.
- IT'S NO TIME FOR KIDDING.
I WOULDN'T KID.
- OH, MY GOD.
- NO.
- I CANNOT BELIEVE
THESE MOTHERS OF DEVILS.
- YEAH.
- WELL, VERY WELL, THEN.
SINCE YOU HAVE ALL FAILED,
I WILL TELL YOU HOW WE
WILL DESTROY THE NONBELIEVERS.
I HAVE DEVELOPED
THE SMALLEST BOMB POSSIBLE.
AND IT FITS PERFECTLY INTO THIS,
A FULL-SIZED TUBE OF TOOTHPASTE.
YES!
IT'S REALLY GREAT, ISN'T IT?
I MEAN, IT'S THE--
- DON'T DO HIM LIKE THAT.
- WHAT'S GOING ON OVER HERE?
WHAT'S THE SITUATION OVER HERE?
- OKAY.
IS THERE A VERSION
OF THE TOOTHPASTE BOMB
THAT COMES IN TRAVEL-SIZE?
- YOU KNOW WHAT?
IT'S LIKE THEY'RE IN OUR HEADS.